جمال وليس اي جمال انه جمال علمي مدروس
تاريخي
قدم لنا في قائمه عالميه لاوسم رجال
العالم ريجيه جون بيدج الممثل الذي اشتهر
بمسلسل نتفليكس برجر صنف الرجل كاكثر
وسامه في العالم بعد ان خضع لتحليل وبحث
علمي خيم الدراسه اظهرت ان وجهه مثالي
بنسبه 93% وفقا نسبه الذهبيه اليونانيه
للجمال والتي تقيس الكمال الجسدي استخدمت
الدراسه بقياده الجراح
تقنيات رسم الخرائط المحسوبه الحديثه
واساليب عاليه التقنيات تسمح بحلب بعض
الالغاز التي تجعل الشخص جميلا جسدها قدمت
نفس الدراسه التي نشرت في صحيفه ميترول
بريطانيا الممثله
قائمه اكثر الرجال
وما هي المعايير العلميه الطبيه التي تحدد
وسامه او جمال الرجل بالنسبه للرجل هو
طبعا في فرق ما بين الجمال والوسامه لفظ
كلمه جمال ينطبق على المراه اكثر من الرجل
يعني بالنسبه للرجل فوسامه الرجل هي الاهم
هي هذا الموضوع يعني بدنا الناحل لغويه
عشان نكون صحيحين
النظريات هذه في الاساس النظريه الذهبيه
هذه في الاساس كانت
معماريه يطبقوها على كل حاجه في الحياه
يعني كانت طبقت على مثلا على الاهرامات
لكن همم
العلماء الرياضيات
حتى بالنسبه لتكوين جسم الانسان لكن هل
هذا همم صحيح ولا لا هل هذا ممكن
بصراحه يعني
بعض انه همم علميا ينطبق كده لانه هذه
النظريه لا تراعي مثلا البشره تجاعيدها
البشره لونها البشره نسبه همم البثور
والمسامات فيه هذه تفضل دكتور جمال لماذا
لا نرى عربا ضمن تصنيف الجمال حول العالم
ما الذي ينقص الرجال العرب لكي يصنفوا
بالاكثر وسامه
لا ينقصنا عرب
ينقصنا اعلام عربي ينشر الثقافه هذه
ينقصنا علماء عرب يطبقوا بعض النظريات على
هذا المجال العرب الموهوبين والعرب اللي
عندهم امكانيات موجودين وبكثره لكن اللي
ينقصنا تركيزه الاعلام عليهم هذه النظريات
همم الاشخاص اللي بيعلنوا عنها اشخاص
بيحاولوا يستقطبوا الاعلام لهم اكثر من
انهم ينشروا حاجه علميه واضحه قال احنا
موجود هنا الاشخاص لكن ينقصنا تركيز
الاعلام
ده هناك اقبال من الرجال اجراء اجراء حتى
تجميل يصبح اكثر وسامه
الاقبال الاقبال في السابق كلنا بنشوف
تقريبا
95% من المرضى او المراجعين في عيادات
التجميل يكونوا من النساء الان اصبحوا
اكثر من كده بكثير يعني الان يمكن
80% نساء 20 % رجال والرجال بيهتموا اكثر
شيء
ومنطقه المكشوفه في الجسم يعني همم وبعضهم
الصغار في السن بيهتموا بالجسم من ناحيه
السكس معكم
[موسيقى]